I'm on the VA team for around five years
and when I started on v8 I had probably
written like 20 lines of JavaScript in
my life before so you can imagine that I
was well prepared to work on a
JavaScript engine but I did some other
stuff that might be related to my work
so first of all first of all don't panic
this is going to be very technical but
you don't need to get every detail so I
just want to get you some understanding
of the interesting complexity that sits
underneath new language features and in
general JavaScript VMs I I will publish
this late nights later and you can have
a look if you want to know more you can
also ask me so I can also respond to
questions so let's play a bit of
buzzword bingo first what do we want to
do or what we want to accomplish with
the v8 engine or in general with
JavaScript engines we want to empower
you to ride modern idea Matic JavaScript
that can be run everywhere so these
buzzwords modern used in latest features
because that's what makes JavaScript
great today
don't write yes five code maybe because
that's kind of ugly unless you like it
also right idea Matic JavaScript so
don't program to implementation details
of the browser but instead write code
that you can understand in a couple of
years because otherwise it will just
want you and trust me I know what I mean
and JavaScript is pretty universal today
so it doesn't matter where on what kind
of application you're working on
javascript can be used for almost
everything so be it machine learning be
it your HTTP server I guess even some
parts of the ioss are running on
JavaScript at least I heard rumors so
it's just everywhere and we want to
empower you to be able to use it
everywhere today I'm going to focus on
this aspect of modern JavaScript and I'm
going to tell you what I mean by that
but first let's have a quick look at the
history of JavaScript so it all started
in 1996 when someone coined the term
JavaScript after
had two other names before and the first
serious version was 1997 when the ACMA
script standout was formed and it
started to get a bit more serious not
just a toy language but it lasted until
20,000 actually until 22,000 until it
was really considered usable when es3
came out and then a lot of time passed
by and I think many people on the planet
just hope that JavaScript will disappear
because it was so terrible to use it was
just a toy language and then something
magical happened then yes five was
eventually published so we skipped the
four because of reasons and that was
when people started looking at
JavaScript like oh yeah maybe we can do
some applications with that even and
then the glorious day started so then we
got year six which we later renamed to
es 2015 we switched to a yearly cycle so
we got yes 2016 yes 2017 and we are
about to publish
yes 2018 in a bit there's a different
way to look at this so there's this
scale
essentially until like after years five
everyone
just hated JavaScript except for a few
people but the majority of people just
said I don't want to write JavaScript
and then there was a period where it was
like okay maybe and now everyone wants
to write JavaScript and wise man once
said so this is Brendan Eich which was
the creator of JavaScript I was still
the creator of JavaScript and he said
one day always bet on JavaScript you
even said that before javascript became
so popular and he was right so back then
it was always die again you cannot use
JavaScript for that you cannot use it
for that you cannot use it for that and
in the end we could use it for
everything so we can just put any
application write it in JavaScript if we
want to so he was kind of a visionary in
that way so what's inside of JavaScript
today so the latest standard from last
year contains a lot of awesome features
in addition to the ones that were
already in es5 so we got classes we got
proxies we got promises we get
async functions we have arrow function
and so on and so on so lots of features
so from a pure programming language
perspective javascript is a pretty
decent language nowadays how did we get
there it all started essentially with
es5 that standard was 258 pages so you
could probably write and yes 5vm in a
couple of days couple of weeks I don't
know depends but it was kind of decent
so then eventually es6 happened and it
was also kind of a bump already so all
of a sudden the standard is twice as big
as before it's the language grew
immensely and then the latest standard
that we have nowadays is es 2017 and
that's already eight hundred over eight
hundred pages almost nine hundred pages
so that's a factor of three point four
increase so we have a hard time keeping
up with that
so not just implementing all the
features but also making sure their work
reasonably well in dev tools that work
reason you agree they give you a
reasonable performance and all of these
things that we need to worry about in
the end and we don't even know how big
es 2018 is going to be because we
haven't done the PDF version of that yet
there are some details but it's probably
going to be about modern thousand pages
and in years 2015 es 2018 you get these
amazing new features among them there
are async generators and acing iterators
which are probably going to change the
landscape quite significantly so the way
we write asynchronous code in the future
is going to be very different from the
way that it was written like two three
years back also we have our object rest
and object spread which is pretty neat
and a lot of very useful regex features
made it into the standard and the best
thing about it you can use all of that
already in Chrome so Chrome 64 and no.10
support all of these new features
already so if you check the table the
so-called keg next table which you
cannot really see well on the slides but
there's these columns for Chrome you see
that everything is green besides shared
array buffers which had to be unshipped
for security reasons when the
factor thing happened but besides that
all the features are already available
and the other browsers also catching up
and notate you can see the node 8 column
not at all so almost supports everything
except for the latest
yes 2018 features but no 10 supports all
of them and it not we didn't need to
uncheck shared array buffers so I also
want to give you a brief overview of
house how new language features are
being introduced to the language so
nowadays we have the tc39 committee
which is responsible for evolving the
language specification this is a
committee of language experts but also
our browser vendors and people from the
node community and from other JavaScript
and better JavaScript users and if
you're interested you could even get
involved yourself so most of the stuff
happens on github nowadays to encourage
to encourage involvement and the process
there's a formal process for a new
feature every feature starts add what we
call stage 0 which is a strawman and
it's just ok I have this crazy idea how
about we just add some new feature to
the language you don't need to bring
anything just maybe a rough idea then
it's already stage 0 so the next stage
is stage 1 and at that point it turns
into a proposal and you have to bring
some demo or a polyfill that at least
describes or bid lays out the idea of
how the feature is going to work and
there's still no formal requirement for
spec text just some JavaScript and maybe
some user feedback and all of this this
is stage 1 so stage 2 is a bit more
serious that's when you need to start a
draft so you need to formulate it in
terms of the spec language the spec has
its own language and you need to
consider api's and at least the rough
semantics should be clear and they
should make sense in the in the world of
existing JavaScript stage 3 is when it
gets serious there's everything
that reaches they trees considered a
candidate for the language and that's
when we are essentially waiting or that
when we get into the equation and start
implementing this in the browsers and
once there are two compatible
implementations which currently means
there are two browsers that ship it it
Stage four and considered this is part
of the language now okay so how does
this look like in v8 land we usually get
involved or get at least my my teams are
involved when it's stage two because
then we are considering implementation
and maybe thinking about how this fits
into the rest of the VM from that we go
on to sense and intend to implement so
that everyone else okay we are going to
implement this update from starters and
come up with the design all this works
and some initial prototypes usually we
derive it from things that are before it
registered to nowadays it's usually
already in Babel or webpack or some of
these tools so we already can take some
ideas from that and turn that into a
prototype from that we create what we
call a baseline implementation which is
just first working implementation that
we think ok we can ship this and this
based on implementation is then staged
which means there is a flag that you can
pass to Chrome to an evil it and
eventually after this had some coverage
we stay every ship it and then we can
you can use it without a flag in the
browser and that's when it gets
interesting because the baseline
implementation is usually just just get
it working but to have a new feature
which is then terribly slow this is not
going to be amazing and not going to be
used a lot also if the new feature
doesn't integrate into dev tools this is
also not going to be used very well so
you will just have the developer
experience will suck so then we start
thinking or we start seriously thinking
about ok how can we make this fast how
can we make the developer experience
great and for this thing we actually
rely a lot on developer feedback because
javascript is so complex we can
essentially we can make everything fast
if we want with some exceptions but if
we in
best in one fast part and that is not
the likely case that's not what you're
going to use then we're wasting
everyone's time and we're just making
the vm complex for no reason
so here if you want to get involved this
is where you could get involved in VA
and I want to show you one of the latest
features that we shipped in Chrome which
is big int you might remember this slide
that I had yesterday anyone figure out
why this is happening
okay then I'm going to ruin my joke and
explain to you what's happening here so
the thing is in JavaScript for whatever
reason Brent decided that we base
numbers in JavaScript on float64 this is
a special binary representation for
floating-point numbers and in float64
you have these 64 bits that are
distributed like this so you have an
explicit sign bit which says it's
negative or positive you have an
exponent and you have so-called mantissa
or fraction and then you have this
complicated formula which turns this
into the actual number I could give a
whole talk just about float64 so I'm not
going to bore you with this but what it
essentially means is that you have a
limited range of num integer numbers
that you can present precisely X X
actually it's because of them fraction
because that's what you multiply so you
have up to 53 bits for precise
representation of integers 52 of those
bits are explicitly stored the last bit
is implicit and the range of these
integers goes up to what we are watch
also calls the Mac safe integer actually
it's the Mac safe integer plus one
because for whatever reason the spec
defines Mac safe integer as the largest
integer where you can still add +1
without hitting holes so after that you
cannot safely add 1 because there are
holes in the range of possibly
representable values what that means is
if you take this number and you add plus
1 that still works so you go from 9 9 1
to 9 9 to okay perfect now if you start
adding 2 to this then you also get 9 9
to be
993 is not representable why offload 60
for a presentation now if you add +3
then you see okay now it works again
because this number is again
representable and now the cool part you
can use begins now no it begins no
problem you can represent any big
integer that you want it works okay
there is a limit because of memory but
in general the limit is pretty high so
you're no longer run into this problem
so if you write scientific applications
or anything that deals with money
especially with a lot of money
don't use numbers so use big integers
another example like this so these are
not even very big numbers but if you
start multiplying them then you see
there's something fishy just look at the
last digit but this is zero it doesn't
make a lot of sense if you multiply 3 by
9 that can't be 0 and in fact it's wrong
the real number is actually this fancy
number so 3 3 3 4 4 4 4 4 and so on and
in the end you see a 7 which makes a lot
more sense ok and you can also go nuts
so just this really big number install
precise number so that's an awesome
feature and the best thing about it it's
already shipping since chrome 60 so 67
which we we are going to release next
week I think or it is already release
it's going to be out very soon and all
of this is going to be in no 10 at yes
so you can start using it other browsers
also almost shipping it or at least are
close to shipping something and the
exciting part here is although it's just
the baseband implementation just using
so we hadn't spent any effort optimizing
for specific cases but just the basic
implementation of our big int already
beats all the existing bignum user space
libraries and one of them so be nsj the
green one was heavily optimized and we
are still way faster on average than
that there probably case is when you
have a narrow case then maybe BMJ s is
faster but in general the native
implementation is already very good so
that was a success story but it will be
boring if I stand on stage and just tell
you about success stories so we also
have some accidents along the way of
evolving JavaScript but also catching up
with a VM and specifically on a
performance side so sometimes you wake
up to these weird github pull requests
where you're dragged into and then
there's a lot of text but when you get
through this you see
Oh something went from two minutes to 14
minutes in backpack for and someone on
the backside complained about this that
this is a v8 issue okay so that was
probably me I would not do the one
complaining but the one who broke it
okay so what happened here let's go
through this quickly so there was a
large angle of five project which had a
shitload of modules really a lot of
modules and all of a sudden when they
upgraded to webpack four there was this
one plug-in that just concatenates all
the things as we just learned in a
previous talk
and that was taking 60% of the build
time and that 60% was not a couple of
seconds but since this was such a huge
project it was 14 minutes so they
already started digging into this and
they found out that this is just time
consuming too simple for off loops I'm
going to show you that and if they've
hand optimized it back to four loops
they could get it down to two minutes
again so that means your angle and
developers this is the difference
between them going for a coffee while
they're working or just working on the
project you can imagine it's annoying to
wait for 40 minutes so for your project
to build what should bundle so why did
that happen
actually they started using idea magic
JavaScript modern automatic javascript
in the peg 4 which is great so we
encourage that but something in here was
not quite right so this is the automatic
version pretty decent right so I have
two nested for loops even if you don't
understand how webpack works this code
doesn't look complicated and that was
the hand optimized code against which
they benchmarked and that looks
not-so-nice anymore and what went wrong
here
so in node 8 which was the node version
that they're running on we had a fast
path for array iteration in for off
which is pretty common except that this
fast path for whatever reason didn't hit
here because this new dependencies atom
you know new module dependencies had
different array shapes internal shapes
to the VM and then the VM was like if I
don't know what you're doing it's go
slowmode and that's then 14 minutes
instead of two minutes so if you want to
know more about these things there's a
long blog post explaining how arrays
work in v8 you should probably go up a
couple of coffees when you start reading
this but it's very interesting so what
did we do well actually we've fixed the
problem we widened the fast path once we
knew what the problem was it was fairly
fairly straightforward fast we just had
to come up with a new idea and then we
had a fast path that even is resilient
to things like this and could work and
this fast path is in no 10 and the
peghead this workaround or still has
this work around until they switched to
no 10 and everyone was happy so what can
you do in this case first of all it
doesn't make a lot of sense to measure
your application performance constantly
because if you don't know that something
is slow that's not good if you only find
it out on the customer side then if you
find an issue report the issue so if you
know the issue is in v8 which is not
easy to tell but you can at least report
it to the apex so that's what they did
and then they can involve the right
people or report it to note something do
something not just sit there and
complain because if we if you report
issues we get a chance to fix them or
that packets a chance to fix them and
remember that we are all humans and yeah
we all make mistakes and we are
sometimes wrong so just don't go bashing
on the internet that's not cute okay
and remember this picture from the
beginning so you're a part of this you
can you don't need to sit there and
say oh I cannot do anything you can and
even if it's just reporting an issue
okay another story that was one thing I
started working on end of last year we
get all these cool features promises
async functions async generators and I
want to show you one example of where we
didn't go that well this is very
complicated so I always need to draw
pictures I have a lot of pictures on the
slides don't worry if you don't
understand it immediately you can look
at it later again but let's try so we
take this simplistic example
unfortunately this is almost a simple
thing you can build to illustrate the
problem so there are essentially two
processes running so the log function is
just a helper so you have a count to
process that just asynchronously counts
from zero to K and you have a tick
process essentially they're just
schedules itself yr promise resolve and
counts down from ten to zero okay and
you start both of these processes so you
can conceptually think of this as to the
two concurrent operations running and
the log function is async just to
illustrate the problem with the weight
later and this is you don't need to have
an async function here the async just
that's the same as this and it just
gives you a resolved promise back that
has the value undefined so we stick to
that example so running this in note
eight or in an older version of Chrome
gives you this picture so you see the
processes are interleaved so you get a
tick then your lock then you tick then
your lock then you take the new lock and
so on and the lock gives up earlier or
the count 2 is done when it reaches 3
and the tick just goes on taking the
same code and running this in Firefox
gave us this picture so we were like oh
wait Firefox is wrong turned out it
wasn't Firefox that was wrong it was us
this is pretty me this was hard okay so
we had to dig into this and find out
what was the problem here so why why do
we see a different picture and yeah I'm
going to illustrate the processes
themselves so that you get a
understanding of that individually so
let's start with the tik tik starts with
the value of 10 and then it always
schedules itself as the resolution
callback on a resolved immediately
resolved promise so it all starts with
the invocation of take 10 that creates a
promise that is already fulfilled with
nine because we pass V minus one and two
that we attach tick as a handler which
schedules a promise reaction job that
invokes tick when it's run so there's
nothing else scheduled so we run the
from its reaction job so we invoke tick
9 that creates a promise that is
fulfilled with the value 8 that
schedules another reaction table to
invoke tick that invokes tick 8 creates
a promise and so on ok so this process
is kind of simple to understand kind of
so what's the deal with VA with a wait
if you stare at this page for a while
then you get a terrible headache trust
me I did this I don't know how often so
this is the fist spec text for a wait
and yeah ok
let's not look there just okay let's
understand this by the example so we
have the function count - that's an
async function with loop inside and
inside of the loop there's an a weight
and that weight awaits honor are
fulfilled promise so the only
interesting bits for us are the weight
and the resolve promise so let's
simplify the example to just this one
line
okay so what does it do if we invoke it
the first thing it does it creates this
promise v this is what not what the
weight does but what promise resolve
undefined us the promise is fulfilled
with the value undefined
okay so then a weight kicks in and the
first thing that way it does because
there is this abstract concept of a
venable which is everything that has a
then method on it that accepts two
callbacks so it cannot only pass
promises into a wait but any venable is
fine so the first thing it does it
schedules what the spec holds a promise
resolves de novo job a really terrible
name and this creates a new or and who
hooks is up to a new promise which is
the actual promise of the await so it
waits sorry a way it creates P V comes
from promise resolve okay then wait
create yet another promise T key because
it's called a throwaway promise I'm
going to illustrate why it's called the
throwaway promise and it chains a
reaction onto piece so that when P is
resolved we resume the count to function
that the async function has been
suspended at the point of the away and
only resumed later when P resolves okay
so then we are done with that and we go
on
so we execute the promise resolve then a
bell job which then schedules a promise
reaction job that fulfills the promise P
or that resolved the promise P with the
value from the promise V that's already
tricky okay so far so good
okay then we go on and we execute this
promise reaction job which propagates
the value from the to P so P is also
resolved with undefined now a fulfilled
with undefined and it scheduled another
promise reaction job that when executed
resumes count two and also resolves the
throwaway promise and when that executes
we resume count two and the throwaway
promise is also for third but since
there is nothing chained on that we are
done
that's why it's called the throw away
promise and that's basically how a
weight works so takeaways from this you
don't need to remember this there won't
be a test or anything but takeaways from
this a weight is probably a lot more
challenging than one might think in the
beginning and if your application
depends on things happening in a certain
order
then you will appreciate that this back
is super precise about order and most of
the implementations are correct so now
we are also correct by now anyways we
are still working on a way to make it
faster so despite the overhead you see
that every weight comes at the cost of
at least two additional promises and
three takes to new micro task queue but
we are thinking about ways how we can
hide this additional overhead so that it
still you should use a weight don't
start promise chaining just because you
saw the slide so still stick to a weight
and we will make it fast eventually just
go through example quickly so that it
sticks okay so we have this we take the
Firefox example because it was right and
we actually we start executing count two
and the first thing it does so I take
art the tick because that's
uninteresting
the first thing it does it does
console.log zero then the promise
resolved edible job then the promise
reaction job for the P and then the
promise reaction job for the throwaway
promise and then we are done again so
this is why we see three ticks in
between okay
so what what happened in v8 why hope
story what happened in notate actually
so the thing was we we had an
optimization in there where v8 was like
yeah okay if I see a full food promise
what's the point of doing the resolved
enabled job because it will just
propagate anyways and so the
optimization went like this where we
were like okay it's already full third
so just create the final promise
reaction job and so we only had one tick
to the micro test queue but the
this is observable and if your
application depends on this you will
have a hard time debugging this you will
probably scream and just give up on this
I would do this so we had to remove it
and when you see such a committee in v8
and there are already a couple of
dangerous words in there as fast path
bypassing benchmark you are something
was not so good okay so it's gone it's
fixed and we'll probably back merge it
to node 8 so I just learned this when I
was preparing the talk last week so I
hadn't had time to do this but we will
also fix it in no date
okay so takeaway from this section
scheduling is well-defined of all these
things and this is a good thing because
then it's predictable so just otherwise
switching between not 8 no 10 or
switching between Firefox and an older
version of Chrome and all of a sudden
you get different order and your
application misbehaves it's not good you
don't want that the optimization
potential on the one hand side is pretty
limited because the spec is has pretty
clear steps that we need to follow but
actually a challenging problem is also
an interesting problem an easy problem
is not really an interesting problem so
for us it's a challenge and for you it's
a cool feature and as you saw it's also
very easy to get it wrong so we had zero
test coverage for this of course so if
you don't test your stuff then it might
break and you might even ship the wrong
thing to millions of users or billions
of users but nonetheless we made some
significant improvements already on this
and this is what we got from basically
the 85.5 which is the word or what's the
version in node 7 so that's the light
blue line to what we have a node in the
eight six point seven which is now in no
10 which is the dark blue and you can
see that there are like almost 10x
improvements on these promise benchmarks
and a single bit benchmarks so we do our
best to not only provide you with the
features but also make sure that it has
decent performance and that you can rely
on it so conclusion from that talk
I hope you're still here and mentally
somewhat JavaScript is a pretty pretty
great language nowadays it has all these
cool features that are the cool
programming which is had before and the
JavaScript developers when I cannot use
anything event nowadays it has it so you
can use it and you should and make sure
to not express implementation details
unless there's a real reason for this
select in this case of that pack okay
they had to mitigate the problem okay
it's fine just implement something that
works well in the engine but in general
just try to write idea medic code
express intent and not implementation so
that you can maintain your own code and
if you find something that is not
working well report it otherwise we will
if we don't know that there's a problem
then there's zero chance that we can fix
it if we know that there's a problem we
can still ignore it or say hello I don't
know but at least we know it yeah we are
on Twitter or you can follow us make
sure you get the vhj s unless you were
interested in fruit juice this is v8 and
also notice that we have more followers
so I guess more people interested in VM
stand in futures and you can also follow
me although Twitter locked me out today
with the GT GDP our mess but maybe one
day I'll be back on Twitter yeah and
that's it for me thanks
you